speaking of stress april is stress
awareness month now through the pandemic
there's been plenty of stress for health
care workers yeah and now research shows
virtual reality can help calm frayed
nerves john langler takes a closer look
working in healthcare is stressful it
can be intense demanding and it never
seems to end to get out of that
environment there might be a better
solution than just a quick breather
chris miller is an er nurse in ohio he
says the pandemic created extremely
tough obstacles surge after surge it's
just really difficult because
historically you would come to work and
you knew that you signed up for a
stressful job but
you could kind of leave that at work and
now with the pandemic it's it's
everywhere to combat the stress anxiety
depression and burnout ohio university
researchers created a tranquil virtual
reality experience immersing employees
in nature
the three-minute 360-degree experience
takes them into a lush green forest it's
a moment of respite in a very chaotic
overwhelming situation it gives you an
opportunity to get away to escape into
nature and we know the health benefits
of being in nature
dr elizabeth beverly led the study this
is a brief accessible intervention it's
very low cost it works for anyone who's
on the unit and we were able to reduce
stress we also found that this
difference was a big difference
the vr experience was very impactful for
miller you really get that opportunity
to apply it your mind and and you know
get your thoughts to really focus on
something something beautiful
researchers are looking at long lasting
benefits to this virtual reality
experience and they're introducing other
scenes to try and help staff relax
john langler live local now